bonsoir à vous filer progrès merci
d'être en direct avec nous ce soir sur
rtl france on va bien sûr parler de ce
vaccin astrazeneca tout juste approuvé
par le régulateur britannique mais
d'abord un point quand même sur la
manière dont se déroule au royaume y la
campagne de vaccination se déroule très
bien apparemment puisque il ya plusieurs
centaines de milliers de d'anglais qui
ont été vaccinés notamment des gens très
âgés de l'équivalence qu'on appelle des
ehpad en anglais et puis du personnel de
santé et ça va ça va continuer et avec
l'arrivée de celui d'astrazeneca
il ya un véritable changement puisque
aujourd'hui et les autorités
britanniques ont annoncé leur volonté en
gros de vacciner tout le monde
c'est ce qui va vraiment modifier les
choses
il ya des raisons à cette explosion du
nombre de nouveaux cas les hôpitaux qui
sont en partie submergée mais là on est
dans une situation qui ressemble à ce
qui se passe en israël qui est un pays
mais c'est quand même très intéressant
de voir quel pays de 60 millions
d'habitants va être capable probablement
de vacciner toute la population à
vacciner tout le monde ça pourrait
vouloir dire peut-être un vaccination
rendu obligatoire ou pas du tout ça je
ne peux pas vous dire je connais pas la
situation en angleterre là dessus je
pense que les anglais sont des gens
pragmatiques il se pose pas des
questions invraisemblables comme en
france avec des situations compliquées
on demande d autorisation avec une près
une pré discussions avec un médecin puis
ensuite une après en face et ses rangs
des choses très compliquées en france en
angleterre gens pragmatiques décision
efficace et ça marche
et alors astrazeneca semble présenter
certains avantages par rapport au vaccin
father biotech a cessé la réalité
peut-être qu'il est mieux meilleurs
qu'aux vaccin ou pas il a comme avantage
d'être moins cher et de ne pas
nécessiter d'être conservée à moins 70
ce qui est un gros avantage pour les
allées britannique elle a aussi
l'intérêt d'être fait par une boîte
pharmaceutique anglaise astrazeneca
donc on est dans la situation absolument
idéal pour la pour la grande bretagne
qui a mis en place des centres de
vaccination extrêmement efficace à
l'instar de ce qui se passe en france
alors vous dites que la campagne de
vaccination devrait s'accélérer au
royaume uni ce vaccin va vraiment
changer la donne il a été calculé par
les épidémiologistes anglais que si 40%
de la population étaient vaccinés on
diminue l de 90 % la mortalité
ça c'est quelque chose de très important
et progressivement on arrivera
l'immunité collective donc l'éradication
de cette maladie
ce vaccin comme les autres faïza john
tate
il est efficace sur le virus mutant
pour l'instant et aucune raison de
penser qu'il ne l'est pas c'est ce que
ce qui est sorti actuellement cela dit
pour le savoir il va falloir qu'on
administre ce vaccin et qu'on regarde ce
qui se passe pour les personnes qui ont
été vaccinées donc ça va prendre un
petit peu de un petit peu de temps mais
je pense qu'on n'a aucune raison à ce
jour de se poser cette question la
question théorique et la transmission du
virus à priori par mois d'ici dit
heureuse pour la transmission des virus
je pense que les médias se trompent là
dessus c'est par capa d'efficacité c'est
que ça pas été testé la seule chose
qu'on a essayé de faire aujourd'hui
c'est de savoir si des gens qui étaient
vaccinés devenait malade et on n'a pas
essayé de savoir si transmettait à
d'autres s
et c'est parce qu'il veut pas dire que
ils vont être contagieux moi je pense en
fait qu'ils sont pas contagieux comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui pour tous les
vaccins
simplement ça n'a pas été testée
puisqu'on a fait très vite il aurait
fallu attendre un an ou deux pour le
savoir on présente tout cas sur le vieux
continent le vaccin faveur biotech comme
la panacée à tort ou à raison
le finder est le premier à être arrivé
c'est celui qui a annoncé les meilleurs
résultats avec celui de modern art
illettré il est probablement très très
bien il est aussi le plus cher
il ya le gros avantage d'être être déjà
là et l'information du jour en français
c'est qu'on n'aura pas celui
d'astrazeneca avant longtemps et donc on
est dans une situation extrêmement
délicate dans notre pays avec un vaccin
de pfizer dans les frigos les
congélateurs
mais quand on n'arrive pas à distribuer
on a fait quand même moins d'une
centaine de vaccination à ce jour ce qui
est vraiment rien et d'autre part on a
prévu le gouvernement français a prévu
de vacciner 20 millions de personnes
seulement pourrais-je dire nous dont 10
à 15 par astrazeneca et 5 à 10 par par
files heures ce qui veut dire
aujourd'hui que puisque le vaccin
astrazeneca ne va pas arriver tout de
suite en europe et il faut se poser la
question pourquoi il n'y va pas arriver
tout de suite c'est simplement parce qu
astrazeneca n'a pas déposé de dossier
d'homologation jusqu'à présent il ne
compte pas le faire tout de suite et
pourquoi il comme pas le faire c'est
parce que en fait le gouvernement
britannique a demandé astrazeneca de
garder pour l'instant toutes ces doses
disponibles
or les britanniques vous vous croyez les
autorités françaises lorsqu'elles disent
qu'elles vont rattraper leur retard sur
les autres pays
courant janvier dans le cadre de la
campagne de vaccination
oui puis on va raser gratis demain matin
c'est bien connu il va y avoir du soleil
en janvier etc
non la situation à ce jour on rattrape
jamais un retard premièrement et si on
le rattrape c'est parce qu'on a un plant
changer tant qu'on n'aura pas modifié le
plan de vaccination français démontrer
aux français on a véritablement les
moyens logistiques de le faire ça va
s'améliorer très très doucement c'est à
dire qu on ne rattrapera jamais ce
retard
dernière question aussi les progrès
laisse qu'il faut se faire vacciner
moi je vais me faire vacciner le plus
vite possible probablement en grande
bretagne puisqu'en tant que crocs et
imperial college avoir droit de faire ça
et moi je je je pense que toutes les
personnes de plus de 50 ans ont un grand
grand intérêt à se faire vacciner parce
que le risque est important pour eux
mais en réalité une grande partie de la
population a intérêt à le faire surtout
si on a une obésité un diabète ou autre
autre problème
je rappelle quand même que même les
jeunes de 20 ans 30 ans peuvent faire un
une maladie sévère et être embêté
pendant des mois avec des grandes sait
quelle est donc cette maladie est
bénigne pour personne parfois les
symptomatique c'est très bien mais pour
les autres elle peut être vraiment
sévère et durer très très longtemps
merci beaucoup philippe froguel
chercheur généticien professeur à
l'impérial collège de londres et à
l'université lille 2